il ya 7 ans j'ai perdu ma voix alors
évidemment là je suis en train de vous
parler donc manifestement je les
retrouvais mais pas complètement et je
suis bien décidé à le faire a retrouvé
complètement ma voix et à comprendre ce
qui s'est passé
du coup j'ai pris les choses en main et
puisque vous raconter tout ça
[Musique]
vous savez peut-être si vous êtes des
fidèles j'ai joué au rugby pendant
longtemps et puis un jour j'ai pris une
cravate une cravate c'est ça
oui je précise que sur la vidéo là c'est
pas moi c'est christophe dominici sur
dominici qui se prend une belle cravate
par la vite et je précise aussi que la
vitz et le nom du joueur qui met la
cravate comme ça tout est clair bref
voilà j'ai pris une cravate c'est à dire
un coup violent au niveau du cou et plus
précisément au niveau du larynx et une
partie du coût et notamment dans le
secteur il ya les cordes vocales la
trachée et c'est ce qui s'est passé
ensuite c'est que ça m'a fait très mal
j'étais un petit peu agacé mais ça va
pas sans le lendemain matin je me suis
réveillé et j'avais effectivement perdu
ma voix j'espère gta muet mais j'étais à
quasi aphone serge avait vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à faire sortir
des sons ça va durer comme ça pendant 24
48 heures et puis progressivement j'ai
récupéré une voie qui a été très rock
pendant plusieurs jours ça monte ça
descend ça c'est un petit peu comme les
adolescents qui sont en train de muer ça
a duré comme ça pendant un petit moment
et puis j'ai fini par retrouver ma voix
d'avant ou presque parce que je m'en
suis pas rendu compte sur le coup ne
s'était pas tout à fait le cas au fur et
à mesure des mois et des années je me
suis rendu compte de plusieurs choses
d'abord j'avais de plus en plus de mal à
pousser le volume de ma voix c'est là
que j'avais beaucoup de mal à parler
fort à crier à prochaine élection du
maire j'avais aussi beaucoup de mal à
parler pendant longtemps c'est que je
fatiguais au niveau de la voix si vous
êtes venu me voir en convention par
exemple le fait de parler toute la
journée avec des gens c'est très cool au
demeurant mais c'est souvent dans des
environnements assez bruyant en fin de
journée j'avais vraiment plus de voix
j'étais exténué donc ça c'était aussi un
souci est le troisième souci c'est que
j'ai perdu
upa tous les aigus mais une bonne partie
des aigus c'est à dire que je ne peux
plus poussé des cris stridents
c'est peu handicapant
au quotidien je pousse assez peu de cri
strident comme ça spontanément mais
c'est quand même embêtant et ça a un
autre souci c'est que bah je peux
quasiment plus chanter en tout cas je
vais vraiment je suis très très limité
au niveau du chant c'est pareil je suis
pas un immense chanteur mais bah j'aime
bien chanter et je ne pouvais tout et
puis récemment avec mon métier faire des
vidéos sur youtube faire des vidéos
ailleurs joué la comédie etc
je me suis rendu compte que c'était
quand même un petit peu embêtant de ne
pas pouvoir faire ce qu'on voulait avec
sa voie d'être fatigué au bout d'un
moment quand on parle beaucoup parce que
parfois quand on tourne on répète
beaucoup les mêmes choses ont fait
plusieurs reprises et c'est donc ça
c'est le premier truc ça va un petit peu
ça a commencé un petit peu handicapé
dans mon boulot et puis l'élément
déclencheur ça a été une soirée
avant l'été avec des amis où ça a mal
tourné
pourquoi pour qu'est ce je ne sais pas
il se trouve que on faisait un petit
apéritif convivial à la maison avec des
amis il se trouve que j'ai un micro à
karaoké qui me sert essentiellement à
faire l'imbécile avec leur avec l'écho
et puis quelqu'un s'en est emparé et
c'est parti en karaoké
j'ai passé la soirée a passablement me
faire chier n'ayons pas peur des des
métaphores fécales parce que je ne
pouvais pas chanter tout le monde
chantait tout le monde rigolait et moi
j'étais dans mon coin
le som l'aigreur donc très mauvais
convives pour la soirée et ça m'a encore
plus fait chier vous imaginez la dose et
je me suis dit vraiment c'est ça paraît
anecdotique mais à la suite de cette
soirée je me suis dit je prends les
choses en main et j'ai pris un rendez
vous pour la rentrée que je viens
d'avoir la un rendez-vous qui s'appelle
un bilan phoniatre hic alors un bilan
phoniatre hic qu'est ce que c'est c'est
un bilan avec une phoniatre voilà et une
fois n'ya trt c'est un médecin qui est
spécialiste de la voix donc mais j'y
suis allé mon camarade amis cadreur
monteur scolopendre romain m'a
accompagné et voilà comment ça se passe
alors d'abord on discute avec le médecin
donc la phoniatre la spécialiste de la
voix qui s'enquiert un petit peu sur
tout ce qui peut influer sur ma voix
dans mon état de santé dans ma
morphologie dont les antécédents donc
tout ce qui concerne les toulon les
voies respiratoires le coup le nez la
tête
globalement la push
[Musique]
arrêtez les dents cassées oui de la tête
devant mais pas au rugby par contre
ensuite la phoniatre mamie un collier
autour du cou un comme un collier de
chien sauf que avec des capteurs dessus
pour mesurer la fréquence et la
régularité de ma voix en me faisant
faire des petits sont à fait à ses côtés
et en me faisant lire un texte ces
petites électrodes qui se trouvait sur
le collier ont mesuré ont analysé tout
un tas de données concernant ma voix les
vibrations la hauteur etc
l'examen cet appel une électro la ringot
graphie et ça a déjà permis d'y voir un
petit peu plus clair donc déjà la bonne
nouvelle c'est que mes cordes vocales
fonctionnent elles sont pas elles sont
pas bousiller elles sont même pas
vraiment abîmé à priori à ce stade de
l'examen vous allez voir quand on va en
savoir un petit peu plus mais quand même
le médecin a bien noté que j'ai la voix
un petit peu rock que je force sur les
muscles du cou quand je suis en train de
quand je suis en train de parler et que
a priori mes cordes vocales se referme
pas parfaitement bien et qui a un petit
peu d'air qui passe l'électro la
radiographie ça aussi permis de mesurer
le nombre de fois où mes cordes vocales
se sont ouvertes et refermer pendant la
lecture du texte
alors voilà si vous voulez tout savoir
ça fait deux mille trois cents fois en
ce qui me concerne ça a l'air d'être
beaucoup comme ça pour un texte qui est
pas qu'ils aient pas si long mais en
vrai c'est pas tout à fait à ses
premiers éléments deux premiers éléments
de réponse et elle a aussi comparé le
temps d'ouverture et le temps de
fermeture de mes cordes vocales qui
normalement devrait être égale ou à peu
près et là c'est pas tout à fait le cas
donc elles sont pas bouvier mes cordes
vocales mais il se passe quelque chose
donc on passe à la deuxième partie du
bilan la deuxième partie du lion c'est
ce qu'on appelle une laryngoscope y est
ça consiste à entrer une petite caméra
si vous voulez dans la bouche pour voir
le fond de la gorge le larynx et les
cordes vocales pendant que je parle
pendant que j'aimais des sons alors pour
saler pour ceux qui connaissent parce
que j'étais quand même pas tranquille en
arrivant c'est moins méchant qu une
fibroscopie quand on passe un tuyau par
le nez pour aller regarder dans le fond
c'est moins méchant c'est pas fou quand
même
mais bon et donc ça a permis de
confirmer ce dont on se doutait déjà un
petit peu après la première partie du
bilan après l'électro la radiographie
c'est à dire que effectivement les
cordes vocales sont nickels n'y a pas de
lésion il n'y a pas de ya pas de
problème mais il se passe quand même
quelque chose là dedans ce qui se passe
là dedans c'est que je suis pas
symétriques je suis un peu des biens des
papas moi mon larynx
d'après la fenêtre ce qui s'est passé
c'est que au moment du choc
on larynx c'est un petit peu dévié vers
la droite et que du coup pour compenser
je force du côté gauche sur ce qu'on
appelle les fausses cordes vocales et
que bah ça occasionne des défauts de
fermeture des problèmes de volume des
problèmes aigus et ma fatigue vocale
donc voilà je suis fixé je sais ce qui
m'est arrivé je sais pourquoi mais le
plus important c'est pas ça parce qu'une
fois qu'on sait ce qu'on a
il faut savoir ce qu'on fait en
l'occurrence ce qu'on fait pour essayer
d'arranger ça eh ben ça va être des
séances de rééducation
ces séances de rééducation ça va se
passer avec un ou une orthophoniste
parce que ces spécialistes pour ça je
pars dans un premier temps sur une
dizaine de séances
et puis je revois la phoniatre pour
faire pour faire un bilan mais elle me
dit que voilà ça devrait pouvoir m'aider
à gérer mon souffle et à m'empêcher de
trop forcer donc de trop fatigué pour ce
qui est de récupérer les aigus etc je
sais pas pour l'instant mais en tout cas
elle a bon espoir que ça puisse m'aider
et ça c'est cool
donc moi je suis plutôt content même si
j'ai évidemment j'ai aucune garantie sur
la réussite au final 2
de l'expérience mais qu'est ce qu'il
faut retenir de tout ça d'abord quand il
ya un truc qui vous embête il faut
jamais hésiter à en parler à votre
médecin
il est peut-être l'impression des fois
que c'est d'être moi j'aurais pu me dire
ne pas aller je peux plus crier je peux
plus poussé des cris stridents
oui bah ça m'embête donc j'en parle à
mon médecin
le médecin qu'est-ce qu'il fait soit il
peut régler le problème soit il peut
vous envoyer voir un spécialiste et des
spécialistes il y en a pour tous je
voulais un problème de voir il ya des
faux nez âtre si vous avez un problème
de peau il ya des dermato si vous avez
un problème psychologique
il ya des psychiatres tout ça c'est pas
plus compliqué c'est aussi logique que
d'aller voir un dentiste quand on a un
problème de dents donc ça c'est la
première chose pas avoir peur de d'abord
les remettent pas hésité à essayer de
régler un problème qui vous embête même
si c'est pas dramatique mais ça mais ça
mérite de ça mérite de se pencher dessus
et puis bien évidemment après il faut
faire ce qu'il faut pourquoi c'est
important de se pencher
quand on a ce genre de problème bah
d'abord ça permet soit d'être rassurés
genre y'a rien où il n'y a pas grand
chose soit ça permet de se dire ah il ya
quelque chose mais on peut soigner on
peut faire on peut faire quelque chose
pour que ça s'arrange soit un petit peu
un mélange des deux comme comme dans mon
cas dans tous les cas plus tôt on sait
ce qu'on a plutôt on peut commencer le
traitement éventuel est plutôt on
commence un traitement plus en absence
qui marche et moi on laisse la
possibilité à la chose de s'empirer donc
ça vaut quand même vraiment la peine
donc voilà retenez bien ça si je vous
raconte cette petite expérience et pas
pour le plaisir de vous montrer mes
cordes vocales même s'il est bon elles
sont pas malins on va pas se mentir
retenez bien ça il faut jamais hésiter à
parler à son médecin d'un truc qui nous
embêtent parce que ça nous permet de
savoir ce qu'il ya ça nous permet de
soigner ça nous permet de guérir au
mieux limiter les dégâts au moins mieux
voilà donc n'hésitez jamais pour ce qui
concerne la voie maintenant
là on a un petit peu survolé la question
parce que c'était ses de l'objectif
d'aujourd'hui c'était de montrer le
bilan phoniatre hic est l'intérêt de se
bouger quand c'est quelque chose qui
nous embête mais ce que je vous propose
c'est de se pencher un petit peu
précisément sur la voie sur comment ça
fonctionne comment ça dysfonctionne
c'est à dire comment ça marche et
comment ça comment ça marche pas vous
posez peut-être des questions à ce sujet
auquel cas n'hésitez pas à me les
envoyer par les moyens habituels que
vous connaissez maintenant mais que donc
on est un petit peu partout et puis ben
oui on en reparle très prochainement
dans une dans une nouvelle vidéo
en attendant écoutez ce que je vais vous
proposer ces prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]